[Music]
I'm in Gund Hall which is the home of
the Graduate School of Design and I'm in
the studio space which is where the most
intense activity takes place of design
of analysis and research of imagination
will speak about the architectural
imagination and I'm gonna suggest that
some concept like the imagination is
necessary if we want to treat
architecture as a mode of knowledge the
classical philosopher said the soul
never thinks without phantasm which is
to say that thought needs a material
image something to carry the thought so
we begin to think of the imagination as
bridging the gap between perception and
understanding what's implied is the is
that there's actually a space in the
mind where the work of picturing takes
place the imagination is different from
other mental processes like perceiving
or remembering insofar as to perceive
something requires that something has to
be there and that's not required of the
imagination and even to remember
something the event or the object or the
person it had to have already been there
in order to remember but the imagination
creates its image the image isn't there
until the imagination produces it the
imagination is also different from a
concept because the imagination requires
the materialization of thought for
example I can conceptualize freedom I
can even explain to you what freedom is
as a concept but it's very difficult to
show you freedom in order to show you
freedom I would have to construct a
picture I would have to construct a
scene then I could help you imagine
freedom in that materialization in that
scene in that picturing so we should
think of the imagination as the capacity
for producing images the mental capacity
to picture things and what we want to
show is that there is a specific kind of
imagination which is the architectural
imagination look at these two images
let's say you know nothing about them
you don't
what their function is you don't know
who their patron was you don't know
where they are but you can already start
to compare them nevertheless one is made
of stone the other one is made of white
stuff in glass probably wood or steel
look at how they meet the ground one is
nestled into the ground it's sort of
almost seems to be emerging from the
earth indeed some scholars would say
that it even compares itself to the
landscape and to the mountains around it
almost wants to become like a mountain
now the other one is also very conscious
of the landscape but it's lifted off the
earth
it doesn't emerge from the earth but it
kind of perches on the earth but both of
them are conscious of the ground already
the architectural imagination is
starting to emerge and then we could
also say they have something else in
common they both have a kind of wrapper
which encloses a single volume but the
wrapper is very special it's a modulated
wrapper
it's made of columns even though one has
stone columns one has steel columns even
though the columns have different
spacings the space in between the
columns is important
the proportion of space in between the
columns and the rhythm of the columns is
important and then look at how the
columns meet the horizontal beam or what
we call the entablature in one case
there's a very articulated picture of
the joinery the way the vertical column
meets the entablature
and there are several pieces in between
that make that transition from
horizontal to vertical articulate now
the other one doesn't have all those
pieces but it almost seems like there's
still great thought about the pieces but
it's it's a kind of negation of all the
articulation and yet in the very
negation the intensity of that joint is
still made so what do we have they're
both empty rectangular volumes defined
by a wrapper and the wrapper is
articulated by columns and space with
have a geometry a kind of geometrical
proportional system they both pay a lot
of attention of how they meet the ground
and they both pay a lot of attention
about how they're in a landscape so what
has happened is that we have
constructed and what has started to
emerge is a very particular kind of
imagination that is purely architectural
its independent of the materials its
independent of the function its
independent of who paid for it and we
have adapted a set of assumptions about
one building to a set of perceptions
about another building we've worked
across those two buildings now what's
implied here is that template of things
in some sense had to pre-exists our
understanding of those buildings that
set of architectural characteristics
that they share in common had in some
sense already be there when we start to
perceive those buildings this is nothing
less than the architectural imagination
at work and what we have arrived at is a
fundamental instance of aesthetic
judgment in the comparison those that
set of assumptions emerged and it was it
is as if it pre existed in order that
you could make the comparison in the
first place
so what's happening is that let's say a
very old building is shaping our
perception of a very new building but
also that that more modern building is
shaping our perception of the old
building and it seems as if that
template of items and assumptions that
we made about the rapper about the
ground about the landscape it seems as
if those assumptions pre-existed our
perception